what's happening here they're checking  whether they are media because people  have been masquerading as media white  why are you questioning them please miss  can also wear this work is it possible  yes or no are you getting control of the  streets a fair amount of anger from the  the police who didn't like me  questioning whether he was um he was  identifying or trying to check various  people's identity a lot of there has  been a suspicion that people of  agitators I mean not press but they're  not they're not targeting the media  they're trying to go past the media or  avoid them and direct their attentions  and their focus on on the demonstrators  a number of whom have come it's true  they have come prepared for trouble but  clearly you saw that that police  officers reaction there they're they're  very edgy they're very sorry just trying  to work out what's going on here there's  a fair amount of petrol bombs still  being thrown so we have to be a little  bit careful